Vsauce Kevin here my image and voice
recorded backed up uploaded and saved
forever your cat photos political
arguments the first private message you
sent your future husband or wife your
comments on this video authenticated
labeled and recorded somewhere for as
long as someone is around to keep the
lights on for the first time in human
history ordinary people will never be
forgotten
at least half of what makes you you in
documenting individual identity Jane
Kaplan explains identity as having two
parts there is the subjective view the
self-same you know who you are because
you are you you have your memory which
Oscar Wilde called the diary that we all
carry about with us and then there's
this sameness with another half of your
identity what others can know that
includes classifications others assigned
to you to identify and make sense of you
and until you can upload your
consciousness to brain tube this may be
the only part of your identity capable
of being recorded the categorical
checkboxes and evidence you leave behind
and we've been obsessively trying to
record ourselves long before selfie
sticks the oldest way to archive
yourself is to pass on your DNA and name
offspring have received patronymic and
metronomic names consistently across
cultures and some traditions passed down
the same exact name the longest-running
name suffix tradition came from the
German house of Royce which named every
son Heinrich all the way up to count
Heinrich the 75th who ended the line
with his death as an infant and in 2010
Christopher Columbus xx a naval veteran
who sailed around the world returned to
Panama 500 years after his ancestors
last voyage but the first widely used
device to express our individual
identity to others was the cylinder seal
invented in Mesopotamia they were carved
out of stone and used to create an
impression
in moist clay these seals marked
personal property served as signatures
on official documents and were often
buried with their owners alongside other
precious items like gold and silver by
3500 BC they advanced to state a
person's name occupation and where they
lived for example this seal depicts a
king holding back two Griffin's which
expressed his ability to control the
chaotic forces of nature and these
symbols on the Left represent his
personal identity but cylinder seals
weren't exclusive to Kings and the elite
they were worn around the necks of the
general public and losing one was the
equivalent today of losing your ID and
credit card if you were a weaver your
cylinder seal may feature a spider if
you are a pillar the Weaver you might
include a mark above the spider to
differentiate yourself from Zuzu the
Weaver who places a mark on the right
side of his spider as civilization
advances and communities grow larger it
takes more to stand out esque squirrels
the size of a group of squirrels called
a scurry directly influences the
individuality of signals used to choose
a mane so whether you're talking about
Belding's ground squirrel or high school
the larger the group the more symbols of
individuality play a role in getting a
date the longest lasting human symbols
of identity are set in stone the
pyramids tombs built to protect and
preserve pharaohs and their legacies
were constructed with joints so tight
that no water can get in and from stone
so hard and no water can penetrate it
which is why your neighbor's house may
be falling down when pharaoh Khufu stoom
is still standing after forty five
hundred years from timeless structures
to timeless culture carved in stone on
the front of the temple of apollo at
delphi was a simple aphorism know
thyself the most famous of the 147
Delphic Maxim's list of truths to live
by it highlighted the importance of
identity as early as six
century BC sages leaders and human
experience continued to develop life's
instruction manual but it took another
2000 years for the first evidence of a
common person saving their data every
day diary or journal both words come
from Latin the Aria meaning daily
allowance and dearness meaning of the
day
luke'll and uchi and apothecary who
learned to write by bookkeeping for his
accountant father chronicled the city's
events which were equal parts news and
drama it was eventually copied and
passed throughout Tuscany which makes
land do cheese blog the first to go
viral but his actions were an anomaly
for hundreds of years to follow before
1700 we have accounts of fewer than 500
Diaries total today there are over a
billion users active on Facebook every
day talking about their lives and
checking in on others the oldest known
Diary is Marcus Aurelius meditations in
which he advises do not act as if you
are going to live a thousand years
soon you'll be ashes or bone a mere name
at most and even that is just a sound an
echo but saving sounds wasn't possible
until the development of the phone
autograph Alexander Graham Bell's
version used a severed human ear
attached to a stylus when he shouted
into the ear his voice was etched into
glass our voices were the most reliable
way to pass personal stories through
oral tradition epic tales and song the
first songs were inscribed in Kimia form
on clay but only fragments survived thus
a fellow's epitaph the earliest known
complete song was recorded an ancient
Greek musical notation on a steely a
stone funerary monument no song
oh man all those who do boo-boo gross or
even as people said but better solo no
supper de and there's a reason one of
the oldest songs was carved into a
tombstone death has historically been
our impetus to preserve the details of
life not just marking graves building
temples erecting monuments or painting
funeral portraits but by creating
probate records the word probate comes
directly from the latin pro bari meaning
to prove the documents created at death
to prove a person lived my own middle
name came from my great grandfather
Julius Lieber this genealogy book
contains an entry about him that
describes his entire life a father of
six an engineer a skilled mechanic with
98 words I'm only three generations
removed from having a written legacy
that fits in for tweets the elements of
our identities we want to record haven't
changed much in thousands of years
Egyptian sculptor back created a selfie
of him with his wife in 1345 BC bamboo
slips with a single column of Chinese
characters for like tweets in 300 BC the
Republic of Letters exchanged ideas
across Europe like a 17th century
Facebook group and every one of your
Instagram food photos would be carefully
scrutinized by genre town Brianza Fromm
who said tell me what you eat I will
tell you what you are often abbreviated
to you are what you eat
but the immediacy and the volume have
very recently changed astronomically in
1995 16 million people were connected by
the internet we're now over 3.2 billion
uploading home videos wishing a happy
birthday to our cousins best friends
sister reading about and interacting
with people will never meet face to face
the data we transfer is predicted to
reach 88.4 exabytes per month that's
eighty eight point four billion
gigabytes storage numbers are getting so
big we're struggling to find ways to
label them
and recording equipment that was once
prohibitively expensive is now probably
in your pocket the free apps in a
smartphone represent 900,000 dollars
worth of equipment about 30 years ago
copying a book before the 12th century
was a lonely task reserved for trained
monks that could take a year which is
why one scribal note at the end of a
book stated finally that's finished now
give me some wine
today with a Google Fiber connection in
about three days you could
hypothetically download all 37.8 million
books stored at the Library of Congress
until the end of the late 1800s low
literacy rates meant most people
couldn't write about themselves even if
they wanted to by the 1950s we made a
legitimate attempt to create a database
of dreams and today smart bracelets
record our every heartbeat but heartbeat
data isn't really us so who are we
recording your ID which was developed
after nations realized they could no
longer rely on a note signed by a
dignitary pinned to the Hat of a courier
as sufficient proof of identification
records your height birthdate and eye
color your social media profiles and
identify errs like your favorite music
or sports team friends and pictures of
you wearing your favorite outfits it's a
far cry from the 14th century when the
majority of people had the Wardrobe of a
cartoon character with wanted posters
describing criminals by their one set of
clothes we now have access to a
previously unimaginable number of
identifiers and ways of recording that
are so easy we don't even realize we're
doing it immortality may be part of the
new normal the ancient Egyptians had to
preserve their bodies through
mummification their eternal organs in
canopic jars and their faces with death
masks all in the hope that their soul
would find its way back after death back
home they believed erasing ones memory
on earth would erase their immortality
but the Sumerians those inventors of the
cylinder seal believed there was no head
only hell and by honoring their dead
buried safely below or in a shrine next
to their house by giving them food and
drink by keeping a record of their life
they could avoid the land of no return
a place we might have eliminated without
even realizing it and as always thanks
for watching